der günstigste Porsche 992 GT3 ist
fertig zumindest sieht er von außen so
aus unter der Hülle gibt es aber
unheimlich viel zu tun und vor allem
läuft das Auto nicht genau dem wollen
wir uns heute annehmen ich wünsche euch
viel Spaß mit Folge 5 des Wiederaufbaus
des günstigsten 992 GT3
Deutschlands nun ja einfacher gesagt als
getan dazu aber später mehr wenn ihr das
große Finale des Wiederaufbaus meines
992 GT3 nicht verpassen wollt dann
abonniert jetzt den Kanal seid somit
immer up to date auch für alle kommenden
Projekte so die Karre ist
[Musik]
da und Bremse
mega Alter spitzmäßig so Schlüssel
mitnehmen Papiere nicht liegen lassen
wollen den Dieben ja nicht einfacher
machen als nötig und dann beginnt morgen
der finale wieder Aufbau meines 992 GT3
wir haben alle Teile Karosseriearbeiten
sind gemacht die Lackarbeiten sind
gemacht jetzt heißt es nur noch nur noch
zusammenbauen und hoffen dass alles
vernünftig
funktioniert so wir sind wieder da in
alten Gefilden haben die Karre schon auf
die Bühne gebracht und erstmal eine
Stunde aufgeräumt Akt numo UNO für heute
wir kümmern uns ums Hack alles
auseinanderschrauben Abgasanlage dran
und dann soweit es geht wieder
zusammensetzen soweit es geht heißt in
unserem Fall komplett zusammensetzen wir
müssen eigentlich hinten nicht mehr
weiter dran richtig das ist korrekt
schauen wir mal was das wird allen
Teilen die bis jetzt noch nicht
getauscht wurden ging es also an den
Kragen Stoßstange final zusammensetzen
bedeutet Blinker rein Rückfahrkamera
Kennzeichenbeleuchtung und natürlich die
Stoßstange an sich welche aus drei oder
vier einzelnen Teilen besteht und wenn
wir schon mal beim Zusammenbau von
frisch lackierten neuen Teilen sind muss
die Tür auch direkt drankommen neue
schei rein der gesamte Mechanismus für
die Scheibe Lautsprecher Türgriff und so
weiter und wenn ihr jetzt irgendwann mal
das Gefühl hattet gar nicht alles vom
Prozess gesehen zu haben dann habt ihr
vermutlich recht denn ich habe die
letzten Wochen so viel hin und her
gearbeitet die ganze Zeit zu wenig
gepennt nie Pause gemacht dass ich
gerade genau auf diesem Sitz eingepennt
bin ja
da Rut schon ein bisschen aus und das
für ein paar Stunden während die Jungs
weitergemacht haben keine timelapse Cam
war am Laufen ich habe diese Cam nicht
ausgepackt und es ist 23 Dezember also
vermutlich hatte sich mein Körper schon
darauf eingestellt so langsam mal etwas
Ruhe zu bekommen aber die kriegt er
nicht den wir kümmern uns um die Front
die Front ist unheimlich wichtig auch
wenn hier kein Motor sitzt der beim El
immer hinten im Auto sitzt gibt es eine
essentielle Sache die im
vorderwagenbereich passiert und zwar die
Kühlung die Kühlung die beim Unfall auch
einen richtigen Schlag ab beekommen hat
aber unheimlich wichtig ist weil wir
ohne Kühlung das Auto nicht benutzen
können sollte die Kühlung nicht
vernünftig funktionieren wird der Motor
zu warm und dann haben wir ganz andere
Probleme Kolbenfresser und so weiter
also Motorschaden ist dann nicht weit
also gilt es hier wirklich so sorgsam zu
arbeiten und alles Pico Bello zu machen
aber wir werden es wahrscheinlich nicht
vollenden können wir haben alle
wichtigen großen Teile neu bestellt die
kaputt sind wir haben auf der
Beifahrerseite einen Kühler der noch
ganz war den können wir so benutzen und
das unser Referenzteil auf der
Fahrerseite haben wir alles neu bestellt
also Gebläse Kühler an sich Halterung
Klimakühler einmal alles auf der
Fahrerseite Problem ist uns fehlt
ungefähr jede kleine scheiße hier dieses
kleine Ding fehlt uns dieses gelbe
kleine Plastikteil hier vorne fehlt uns
ganz viele von diesen kleinen
Anbauteilen von denen wir ausgegangen
sind dass sie dabei sind die aber nicht
dabei sind was jetzt bedeutet wir können
das Kühlsystem wahrscheinlich gar nicht
fertig zusammen schustern sondern müssen
auf weitere neue Teile warten das raubt
uns Zeit dieses Projekt ist geprägt von
Rückschlägen immer dann wenn man das
Gefühl hat jetzt läuft es jetzt geht's
weiter kommt es wieder knüppeldick und
in solchen spaßprojekten ist das noch
vollkommen okay aber genau genauso
passiert im echten Leben und das kann
unter Umständen viel gravierendere
Auswirkung haben wir alle wissen dass
wir früher an später denken sollten aber
die wenigsten von uns machen das und
damit das einfacher wird gibt es clar
euren digitalen Versicherungsexperten
clar bietet euch eine 360° Kontrolle
über eure bestehenden Versicherungen und
solche die noch abschließen aber warum
sollte die Altersvorsorge jetzt
überhaupt schon wichtig sein ich meine
die meisten von uns sind in dem Alter in
dem man sich am liebsten als
allerletztes damit beschäftigen möchte
nun ja die gesetzliche Rente hält schon
lange nicht mehr das was sie verspricht
die früher wir uns anfangen mit klag
darum zu kümmern desto mehr haben wir im
Alter davon die ausgebildeten Experten
helfen euch dabei in dem kostenlosen
Gespräch die perfekte Altersvorsorge für
euch zu finden denn so individuell wie
unsere Lebensstile sind kann auch die
Strategie für unsere Altersvorsorge sein
mit der Unterschrift beide der Anmeldung
wird klar euer neuer Versicherungsmakler
und vertritt eure Interessen bei den
Versicherungsgesellschaften aber auch
nur dann wenn ihr es wollt Kar schließt
also keine Verträge hinter eurem Rücken
während ihr am Schlafen am arbeiten oder
unter der Dusche seid ihr habt also
weiterhin die volle Kontrolle ladet euch
jetzt also über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung oder diesen QR Code
die clar App herunter und erhaltet mit
dem Code day 14 und durch das Hochladen
bestehender Versicherung bis zu 45 € in
Form eines best choice Gutscheins Z den
ihr bei unsähigen Partnern wie Adidas
Zalando oder Ikea einlösen vielen Dank
an Kar fürs möglich machen dieses
Projektes und euch viel Spaß weiter mit
dem Video also erstmal weiter mit den
Sachen die wir erledigen können aber wir
haben relativ schnell gemerkt der Tag
muss hier enden wir können nicht
weitermachen zu viele kleine scheißteile
die uns auf halten wir könnten jetzt
weiter zusammenbauen und halbgare
halbkaputte Teile einbauen dann
irgendwann noch mal auseinanderernehmen
das alles noch mal tauschen kleine Teile
fehlen vorne in der Stoßstange kleine
Teile fehlen vom kühlersystem aber das
macht keinen Sinn wir wollen
Originalzustand wir wollen alles Pico
Pico Bello die Liste ist wirklich lang
das ist alles nichts dramatisches aber
es ist wirklich lang also beenden wir
den Tag heute kümmern uns morgen um
pyofuse das Projekt steht dann erstmal
auf unb stimmte Zeit still bedeutet
Weihnachten für mich also nutzen wir die
letzten paar Stunden vor Heiligabend um
den pyofuse auszubauen und dafür muss
das gesamte Armaturenbrett raus wir
hatten ja schon Sitze rausgenommen
Clubsport also überrollkäf und so weiter
rausgenommen jetzt muss aber das ganze
Amaturenbrett raus Lenkrad ist schon
draußen Mittelkonsole ist schon draußen
und das komplette Ding muss einmal
abgehoben werden weil das sitzt kein
Witz an der letzten allerletzten
Position unter dem Armaturenbrett genau
da wo es quasi Richtung Vorderwagen geht
also eine beschissenere Position kann
man sich nicht vorstellen die Jungs sind
am Schrauben am Schrauben am Schrauben
willst du sagen das so mit die größte
Scheißarbeit die man an dem Auto machen
kann ist schon ist schon übel auf jeden
Fall wenn der pyofuse drin ist ne dann
kann ich theoretisch also nicht dass ich
es will aber dann wird der einfach auf
eins sofort wieder starten genau dann
startet direkt
wieder
ja als wäre nicht schon genug Arbeit
gewesen ganz Armaturenbrett und die
Träger hier rauszunehmen jetzt ist hier
noch der ganze Verdampfer Klima
Wasserkasten also der ganze
verdampferkasten noch drin hier die
Klimaleitungen die müssen wir dann vorne
sind die durchgeführt müssen lchrauben
und dann geht hier natchch noch
Kühlwasser durch bzw für den Innenraum
zu wärmen das heißt wir müssen vorne
noch alles abmachen glücklicherweise im
Auto kein Kühlwasser drin und dann wenn
man ganz da unten alles aus ut hat da
unten sitzt der
Hauptsicherungskasten also ist noch ein
bisschen Arbeit wirklich beeindruckend
wie viel scheiße da raus muss bevor wir
dieses winzige kleine Teil tauschen
können aber erstmal 11:28 Uhr am 24
Dezember 2023 geh jetzt erstmal mit der
Familie Speisen uns beschenken lassen
und machen dann in den nächsten Tagen
weiter wir sind wieder da nach
Weihnachten ist quasi wie Weihnachten
für uns alle Teile sind da bedeutet wir
können am Auto weitermachen Kön den
Kühler das gesamte Kühlsystem vorne
zusammenklatschen uns danach um pyrofuse
kümmern die Tür den Innenraum ein paar
Kleinigkeiten im Heck bedeutet jetzt
beginnt der richtige Endspurt beim
Zusammensetzen des Autos hoffen wir mal
dass alles so klappt wie geplant als
erstes die Kühler insgesamt besteht das
System aus drei Kühlern einer links
einer rechts und einer in der Mitte so
schauen wir mal ne hier vorne sieht
alles wieder traumhaft aus hier die
ganze Luftführung die Kühler sind fest
jetzt ein vierteltag dafür gebraucht
alles wieder ins Lot gebracht bedutet
wir können uns um die letzten kleinen
Teile im Heck kümmern das Heck hatten
wir ja schon zusammengebaut muss aber
jetzt wieder auseinander also Flügel
runter duckil runter Heckverkleidung ab
und neun Teile dran insgesamt haben wir
das Heck jetzt fünf oder sechs mal
auseinander gebaut ich langweile euch
also damit nicht mehr weiter und wir
kümmern uns final den pyofuse das Objekt
der Begierde und dann natürlich ganz
hier vorne am allerletzten Ecken da
sitzt die dann drin also einmal zerlegen
da ist der Zünder also zumindest das
Kabel zum Zünder ja tauschen und dann
haben wir hoffentlich wieder Zündung
können Auto starten
ne
Alter jawohl es
wird der point of return endlich
finally so alles festschrauben den Onkel
noch da dran und dann alles hier
zusammen pofuse drin wir können das Auto
theoretisch starten es muss aber
trotzdem noch gekühlt also habe ich mich
hinten am Auto um die Befüllung der
Kühler mit Kühlwasser gekümmert während
die Jungs alle finalen Schritte vorne am
Armaturenbrett gemacht
haben was Jonas da gerade macht Batterie
wieder anklemmen ist der letzte Schritt
bevor wir jetzt das Auto testweise
starten können bzw probieren können es
zu starten aber es geht hier nicht nur
ums starten es gibt drei ganz wichtige
Punkte Punkt ein die Karre muss starten
irgendwie muss das Auto an gehen dann
wissen wir unter dem Armaturenbrett
wurde alles richtig verkabelt die ganze
Arbeit alles was sie irgendwo
auseinander gerupft haben ist wieder
vernünftig zusammen und es funktioniert
das ist das allerwichtigste Punkt Z beim
neuen Kühler neues Kühlmittel die Karre
muss kühl bleiben wird das Auto zu warm
müssen wir es ausmachen müssen da noch
mal irgendwas dran machen wir haben es
mit Unterdruck gefüllt also es müsste
eigentlich alles funktionieren und Punkt
3 und das sind nur Style points wir
hören das erste Mal die neue
Auspuffanlage akrapot Auspuffanlage und
den ersten Kaltstart bestenfalls ist
derh dicht und funktioniert und hört
sich gut an genau das machen wir jetzt
sollte das alles funktionieren so wie
wir uns das jetzt vorstellen dann steht
der ersten Testfahrt auf unserer
privaten abgesperrten Teststrecke hier
vor der Halle eigentlich nichts im Weg
soll
ich
[Musik]
go das Auto geht an was für ein
unglaublicher Moment bedeutet Punkt 1
auf der Liste check das Auto geht an
pyofuse ist richtig eingebaut und alle
Bedienelemente am Armaturenbrett
funktionieren auch aber was ist mit
Punkt 2 der Kühlung des Autos die
essentiell ist nicht nur damit wir eine
Probefahrt machen können sondern damit
wir das Auto auch auf eigigen Achse ins
Porschezentrum bringen können wo wir
alle letzten finalen Schritte für den
Wiederaufbau des 992 gt3s machen Alter
haben gerade noch ein bisschen laufen
lassen Temperatur beobachtet und es wird
tatsächlich ein bisschen zu warm den
immer mal wieder gerft MS wir jetzt
schauen was Sache ist die Lüfter vorne
sind beide angesprungen das ist alles
wunderbar aber es wird bisschen zu warm
das ist Punkt 1 und Punkt 2 die
Auspuffanlage öffnet nicht können wir
auch noch mal auch noch mal bei schauen
aber sie hört sich weiß Herrgott in
welchem Zustand sie gerade war sehr gut
an
[Musik]
das Auto steht quasi wieder komplett da
auch wenn wir immer noch nicht fertig
sind wir haben Auto mit Verkleidung mit
Motor mit Armaturenbrett mit Lenkrad
Radreifen im Prinzip alles außer
funktionierendes Kühlsystem und die
gesamten Airbags und den gesamten
Innenraum was soll ich Euch erzählen
Plan war es dieses Auto heute und in
diesem Video Test zu fahren und nicht
nur Test zu fahren weil es einfach
Sachen gibt die in der Werkstatt gemacht
werden müssen aber wir können nicht
fahren weder 100 m auf privater
Teststrecke noch bis nach trie noch bis
ins Porschezentrum wir können das Auto
nicht bewegen bedeutet mehr kosten ich
muss wieder jemanden holen der das auf
irgendein Anhänger oder Transporter läd
ins Porschezentrum bringt und dann dort
die ganze Schose noch mal neu also noch
mal das ganze Kühlmittel raus noch mal
das ganze Kühlmittel wieder rein und
dann hoffen dass es funktioniert wenn
wir nicht irgendeinen größeren Fehler
haben der der uns davon abhält v tig zu
kühlen also Auto läuft nicht und wir
sind nicht so weit wie geplant so ist es
es wäre auch zu schön gewesen wenn alles
auf eins funktionieren würde die letzten
Arbeiten erledige ich mit Robin im
Porschezentrum und hoffe und bete dass
all das bestens funktioniert und uns
keine weiteren bösen Überraschung
erwarten wenn ihr das nicht verpassen
wollt dann vergesst nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren um bei der nächsten und
hoffentlich letzten Folge des
Wiederaufbaus dabei zu sein bis dahin
macht's
gut
[Musik]
ه